so a lot of people have different
reasons as to why they would never vote
Hillary Clinton
whoa hey hey these are nice people these
are nice people now we know that many of
you have countless reasons as to why you
can't stand Hillary Clinton but in
creating this list we had to weed out
some of the issues that would be
exclusive to the right like pro-life
issues or LGBTQA IP issues versus the
left like her donations from banks in
order to try and create a simple master
list of gripes that people can
universally have with presidential
candidate Hillary Clinton number one
she's a liar and I don't mean like kind
of a liar I mean possibly a sociopath
you can start with the big ones the
obvious ones like blaming Benghazi on a
YouTube video after the fact when we
know that to be false or of course the
email server those are obvious when I
say sociopath or at the very least a
compulsive liar what we point to are
lies that are made constantly that don't
really matter when people aren't paying
attention but she lies anyway like
claiming Chelsea Clinton was jogging
around the World Trade Center on 9/11
that was a lie like claiming that she
landed under sniper fire in Bosnia just
like Brian Williams helicopter story
that was a lie like her claiming that
she was named after Sir Edmund Hillary
because he was one of the first people
to climb Mount Everest that's a lie
Edmund Hillary did not climb Mount
Everest until Hillary Clinton was 6
years old so either she has a DeLorean
or she's a compulsive liar this baby
hits 88 miles per hour and it ranges all
the way to her claiming that she was
dead broke when they left the White
House even though they were
multimillionaires or claiming that she
was instrumental to the peace process in
Northern Ireland despite people there
saying she was nowhere to be seen here's
the thing we all know about the big lies
right that have been covered in the
press but what about all of these other
lies that she makes constantly when she
doesn't even stand to gain that much
that's a compulsive behavioral pattern
let's go to number two
Clinton is anti-woman I know the irony
right the first possible female
president hates those with uterus uteri
not only does she believe that women are
incapable of paying for their own birth
control or being responsible for their
own sexual actions and/or employment but
she deliberately intimidated and
suppressed women with whom not only her
husband was having affairs we all know
about that but unwilling participants in
sexual assault cases against her husband
sure you all know about Monica Lewinsky
or Jennifer flowers you probably don't
know all of these names Bill Clinton was
an absolute sexual predator this was
ongoing and Hillary Clinton knew about
it again we're not just talking about an
intern underneath the desk we're talking
about women who weren't even in on the
gag Hillary Clinton made sure they went
away
Oh hashtag you're with her you're an
accessory to rape which brings us to
kind of the same point but we thought it
required its own separate point Hillary
Clinton defended a child rapist and
laughed about it yes really reference is
available at loud or with Crider calm
this is the kind of twisted evil from
the Clintons that has Satan shuffling
papers and hell saying aye we don't even
have an area to process this HR is not
equipped for this PC load letter does
that mean twelve-year-old girl raped in
Arkansas Hillary Clinton who was
recorded on audiotape acknowledged that
she was aware of her clients guilt and
has even quoted as saying he took a
lie-detector test I had him take a
polygraph which he passed which forever
destroyed my faith in polygraphs Clinton
says in the recording failing to hold
back some chuckles speaking of rape
culture number four Hillary Clinton has
taken unbelievable sums of cash in
foreign donations to the Clinton
Foundation not only could this
potentially be illegal but if you look
at the list of countries with whom she
has a cozy relationship for a woman who
claims to be a champion of women's
rights they don't really have a stellar
track record with women's rights gay
rights or rights rights some countries
that gave massive
multi-million dollar sums the Clinton
Foundation includes Saudi Arabia UAE
Oman Qatar cater however you say it
Kuwait Algeria and more I know that all
politicians have some money coming in
from unsavory characters but it pales in
comparison to the way Clintons have
handled their money in foreign donations
it's the backbone of their platform
which brings us to our final reason for
people both left and right to despise
Hillary Clinton she is a crony
capitalist hypocrite quintessential
establishment politician defined not
only does she compulsively lie about
matters that concern national security
like Benghazi or email servers not only
as we've covered does she continually
lie about issues that don't matter like
her name or her daughter jogging around
the towers on 9/11 not only does she
hold herself out as the beacon of
women's equality and feminism well she
simultaneously suppresses intimidates
and silences voices of the victims of
sexual assault on behalf of her husband
not only does she defend a child rapist
not only does she get money from all of
the big banks and countries that want to
kill all the gays and the Jews and the
America not only was she a Republican
until she was a Democrat not only was
she a lesbian until she needed to be
straight to run for office I told him
his wife was a dyke sorry scratch that
one obviously Hillary Clinton is not a
lesbian it's just confusing to keep
track because she was so rapidly against
gay marriage until she all the sudden
became passionately for gay marriage not
only is well I guess that's a lot of not
only that's enough of not onlys when you
put them all together I guess only that
no wonder even far leftists and Bernie
supporters or Susan Sarandon herself
can't get on board with the hashtag I'm
with a train
so let's reappropriation I'm with a
compulsive lying child rapists offending
sexual assault victims silencing
big-bank and foreign donation money
taking flip flopping angry lesbian
sociopaths who may not really be a
lesbian just so we're covered legally
hey if you like this video all the
references are it louder with credit com
you can go there by
licking my face or subscribe with the
button below to videos next to me you
have to click at least one of them
though otherwise you might go the way of
Vince Foster Oh who's Vince Foster
search